Are we live? Right. Nice. Okay, cool. We
are back
for one more week. And yeah, let's see
if people are joining this time.
>> Have the chat open.
>> The chat is open.
>> Yes. And uh yeah, I think YouTube will
work. So that that's fine. That's good.
But uh okay, so I'm gonna do the video
introduction, the same thing, and then
we jump into it. And uh yeah,
that's cool.
Wait, is that connected on X2?
>> I think it is.
>> Yeah, it's live too. Nice. Nice. Nice.
Nice. Let's go. Nice.
>> Yeah, you're streaming. I'm as well.
>> Nice. Nice. Cool. Okay. So,
uh, are you still building an AI SAS?
Uh, no. That's okay. Wait, I'm going to
do it again.
Not AI S B2B SAS. Yes. Yes. Take two.
Let's go. Uh, yeah. Agent, that's for
the editing. Uh, if you forget what I
said before that, but okay, cool. So,
are you still building a beast to be uh
SAS in 26? Because if you're not even
riding the AI wave, what the [__] are
you doing?
Did I whatever I said it?
>> Yeah. Forget about SAS, build with AI.
That's it.
>> Yeah, exactly. So, basically, forget
about SAS and build with has an AI agent
or four AI agents. Even better.
>> Yeah.
>> Have a AI agent managing the AI agents.
>> Yeah. AK. Open CL. Basically, don't be a
SAS. Just use Open CL.
>> Yeah. And it's so much easier to
remember names of your whole team. AI1,
AI2, AI3.
Have you seen like the videos of like
Alex Finn when he has like five agent
like doing the whole stuff and he he
bought
um two two Max Studio to have
>> Yeah, he want he want to he want to
spend like 100 grand on that. Um I'm
curious about what Okay, he has like
agent running 247 but uh what's the
output of that? Yeah, he doesn't share,
but I think his agents are also hiring
agents.
Uh
>> he he said the agents were using CHPD
and cloud as well.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, but like he he
demonstrated on his like last video. Uh
I don't know. Do you watch his channel?
>> Yeah, some videos, not all. Uh
>> Alex
uh
Uh yeah, I spent 20 grand on open claw.
Here's why. Um it's kind
>> I just spent 20,000.
>> Uh it's kind of interesting. Uh here
uh so yeah, he explained like yeah free
uh use local models blah blah blah. So
basically you pay for the like the
server usage aka like Apple Mac Studio.
So it's cool but okay and then it
generated like it vibe coded an app to
show all of the agents and they are
taking meetings aka like they review
each other kind of cool um
and then explain one is doing that uh
yeah since like for example that's the
use case all of the agent are um reading
ready 247 like strategizing
and um basically reviewing all of the
content uh cut the apps that if the AI
or code think it's a good vibe coding
apps that that can run automatically
ship it and then DM original poster it's
kind of cool because for distribution
that's a kid
>> uh
>> yeah but he spends a lot of money on his
Mac minis but how much money is he
spending on tokens
>> but that's the that's the case right
like you buy you buy like um
>> yeah to run it locally
Yeah, exactly. Then it doesn't cost
anything anymore.
But like honestly, I'm use I have like
two clothes cut subscription which is
like 400 a month.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh I don't get like uh I I I have to
use like in like uh I I just switch but
uh I kind of like I don't run 247
but uh I use them a lot.
>> Yeah. Even if you have three, then
spending 10k on a Mac Mini, then $600
isn't that much.
>> Yeah. Yeah. True. Yeah. Just like one
year worth of like cont. But like also
it's it it goes so fast that you don't
know which model will come out in in
three months.
>> Yeah. Or in the next week.
>> Yeah. Like it's I know like
>> because we have many releases in the
last week.
>> That's great. Yeah. Like OP 4.6 six and
Codex 5.3. I love it.
>> Love it.
>> Yes.
>> And like today I I set up like I
reopened the codeex app like you know
the
code code but for codex
and um there is like automation stuff.
So it's kind of like open
but with a codeex interface and I can
have my chrome jobs basically uh in the
UI and um now I'm running code and cloud
code for building and codeex to
monitor everything and like find the
gaps and even like uh uh run the test
every like when I sleep.
>> Yeah. to remind cloud code every 30
minutes to keep on going.
>> Yeah. Or even like, are you sure you
should do that?
>> Yeah. Just throw it in.
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> I don't know what you're doing, but is
this correct?
>> Yeah.
Like to review the plan or stuff like
basically like what do like what's the
Alex is doing on his like agent table
office stuff
>> uh just with a terminal instead of UI. I
think he's doing a lot of stuff for
content anyway because like Yeah.
>> 110,000 subscribers in in 18 months.
Crazy. Insane.
>> Yes. Why would you otherwise build a
classroom for your AI butts?
>> It's it's it's making a good tweet at
for
>> that's it. Is right like uh but yeah. So
for example um okay so if you take like
back to the topic like of the S stuff um
if you take his example
>> Mhm. He built creator buddy. So creator
body creator
>> is said still around.
>> Yes. So
>> like it's still live.
>> Mhm.
>> But so he coded like that. It vibe coded
it because he's not a dev guy, right?
But um
uh I tried it. I spend like one or two
months on it and then I cancel the
subscription because uh code and
everything. Um it's just to tweet better
and it also train of you tweet but no
for example like uh you can pay for the
uh pay as you go on the um
on the X API.
>> Mhm. So
like a SAS to create tweet
and then you have open CL on top of
that.
Uh
where is the value proposition?
>> Well, it was a few months ago
and nobody knows how fast it's going.
It's insane.
>> Yeah. And so Okay. So tomorrow, so you
you want to build a SAS, how do you do
that?
>> Not anymore.
Well, you can, but then it has to be
like really really really big.
>> Yeah.
>> Like something so big that people don't
want to start on it and it it's too
complex to just plan everything and you
need really hard knowledge to build
everything. But if it is something
simple,
yeah, then you're screwed.
Yeah,
>> you had to assess for just for
registering uh mileage on your car for
for your administration for the company.
>> Mhm.
>> You say where you are, you say again
where where you're stopped and it
calculates kilometers and puts it in
your administration. Well, all those SAS
companies, I think they're going to
zero.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
But okay, so the thing is like for us
technical guys like we say, okay, we I'm
going to vibe code that [__] in like a
weekend and then I will have like a um
multi-billion
SAS uh too and I will I will do a better
job than Salesforce, right? Um
yeah, you're right. Like Salesforce is
big. They it serve like million of
customers.
Um so then it's it's harder to uh
to attack the AI age and especially when
they like for example they have created
like the Salesforce SDR Salesforce I
forgot the name of the exactly the name
but it's a AI sales guys
>> Salesforce and okay so uh SDR sales
force AI
um
yeah uh sells like they did like crazy
sales number
um I I will not find it again but
>> yeah but for sure on the smaller
companies who are not so dependent on
the integration of Salesforce in all the
systems
>> yeah and have you ever tried Salesforce?
>> Uh yeah it's complex to set up
>> like Jesus. Well, yeah,
you can start with smaller ones. I I
fully automated. I built my own Zenesk.
>> Exactly.
>> And I did in three days and then I took
like while using it, I asked cloud to
create a new function, optimize it, do
it in a different way and within two two
weeks it was exactly as I wanted to have
it.
>> Yeah.
>> And that was an expensive Sendesk
subscription.
>> Yeah. And plus like now you can include
it to your customer subscription and
stuff like that like you can upsell
provide more value for yeah it's
>> AI bots integrated they talk uh WhatsApp
business API integrated task creation
from tickets time integrated time
registration everything is integrated
and built by my own AI. Yeah, but like
Okay. So, would you offer
a classic SAS UI
or do you think people will use uh
conversational chat like chat GPT
experience in your CRM for you
customers?
>> Yeah, it depends on the user, right? We
will use like the chat GPT version, but
a lot of people don't even know how to
write a proper prompt.
>> Yeah, 100%. And like okay so if you have
a conversational like uh you build a SAS
you build an agent first like a agent
first app
>> um what the [__] do you ask like how do
you Yeah exactly like you're right right
like what do I ask uh to the agent? So I
need to know why am I why am I using the
SAS and I need some like input on
boarding to drive me through the whole
UXUI aka like the Google search box.
Basically
>> you can also turn it around right like
you tell to the AI hey this is what I
have I want to create it myself and
better I don't know where to start
please ask me the questions to
>> to know what you need. Yeah, but see
that
like
saying
ask me questions
to uh for you to get information. That's
not that that it's not like we we know
how to do it ourselves because we spend
the last 18 months with AI tools.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> My mom doesn't understand that. Uh
>> yeah, she asked you who's typing back.
>> Exactly.
So yeah, I I I would be curious like uh
what's the first impression of someone
who like in the last three years didn't
touch that GPT?
>> Mhm.
>> Or do they interact with the technology
and like uh Okay. So you don't you don't
interact with CHP because your corporate
forbid you to do it because uh it's not
in the um list of authorized software.
Um, how do you on board during your job?
Do you use your own personal account and
then but you know
that means like for
crazy um
>> Yeah, but you can also just tell them
use it like you have a new staff member
and talk to it like you would do to an
intern or somebody who is just on his
first day here.
>> Yeah.
>> And start explaining.
>> Yeah. Because like for example a
dashboard could look like a like a
default dashboard but then you have a
button to say add a column and then it
prompt and then like yeah there is
something to do for the product for sure
on the product like a front
um to maybe not having this
conversational
um
UX UI but you have a button it's
completely integrated and for For
example, you create a column to your
dashboard by asking
uh the sidebar to edit the views of your
own dashboard.
>> Mhm. Yeah. So, real time coding without
coding.
>> I like that. But I don't want to
>> that will be cool and I think eventually
we'll go. It's like Google Analytics.
Why would you eventually need a full
Google Analytics dashboard if you have a
MCP server and you can just say how many
visitors did it get today and what's
compared to yesterday.
>> Exactly. That that's um
I think Genfe also for the content need
to be that like it's not okay generate
me an ad for that product. Mhm.
>> It needs to be um
give me a campaign for the la the next
five days for my endle
and then the AI in like inside the
engine needs to like inside the SAS
needs to understand uh this is the
account blah blah blah. So basically you
have a rag on every account kind of like
brand voice blah blah blah and yeah
I think that's that's
>> yeah maybe if you just wait one month it
will be there you don't know
>> or then opus cl is going to [__] like
push MCP server whatever or like a skill
and then oh yeah content creation
>> because I thought the last version of
cloud was good, but this one it just
hits everything spot on directly.
>> Yeah. Like it Yeah, it I think it was
supposed to be five.
>> Yeah.
>> And they say, "Okay, no, let's let's do
something better." And uh because they
have the the hype for Sony 5 and stuff.
>> Mhm.
>> And if if they get that good with a dot
one, then the hype for five will be even
better. like kind of small.
>> Yeah, because right now when I think it
did something wrong, I ask why did you
do this and it says no no I improved it.
>> You see you you can now see this this
and this and then I look really good and
oh it's like yeah
>> like sometimes AI like is like the code
is like uh telling up a solution that I
didn't think about and it's better.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And then you say why are you
doing this and it says it's better.
>> Yeah. Exactly. like yeah at least it
just but it's also maybe I should I
should create a skill for that to
discuss uh
>> to tell you to shut up I am improving
your [__] Yeah, like justify your
design architecture uh decision
like why did you do that? Because yeah,
okay, I'm going to I'm going to take
note of that.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh where is my to-do list? Okay. Uh
>> so your skill will be if you are the
team lead to have your AI challenge the
team lead.
>> Um
yeah. Or justify. Okay. Uh skill
uh discuss discuss
uh
architecture arcture basic
decision.
That's cool. Okay. So, do you use ask
user tool for that?
>> Like get interview. Yeah, sometimes I I
do like I I ask something and then um
I ask I I I prompt uh use ask user tool
to interview me about these features. So
if you need more details blah blah blah.
>> Oh no, I didn't use that. I just use
plan mode and then starts asking the
questions as well.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Like it force um the plane
mode to uh ask question. Sometime it
doesn't but by doing that and it can be
also like way deeper than just the two
three questions because by default it
will only ask two three question because
>> um it's faster to implement so they bet
on the speed of execution
>> but if you increase um if you say that
okay I go deep on the interview blah
blah blah then it will add more
questions and the output should be even
better.
>> Yeah. Yeah. it gets more information.
>> And now I'm I'm uh I add uh I have a a
chart like a a diagram like the you know
when you have the user diagram flow
>> is that the name right? Flow diagram.
Yeah, something like that.
>> And um you see the whole architecture
like for even for like the microervices,
>> you see all of the connection between
all of the services
>> to uh document and justify the
architecture decision.
>> Cool. I love it.
>> Yeah, that's cool.
>> Yeah,
but yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that going to kill SAS?
eventually I think so
>> I don't believe
that we will
because okay so we are dev we are
technical like we we use AI via [__]
terminal
>> I even prefer the terminal
>> me too because like even like the whole
um experience it's more like straight to
the point there is no fancy or like
whatever whatever. Um but for example
like someone who vibe code for the first
time like six months ago like for
example Pangu
>> he use a cloud desktop to you to have
his first experience with cloud code
>> and he didn't know about what a CLI is
but it's normal because he's not dev.
>> Yeah yeah yeah I understand.
>> Yeah. So people even like um that's what
that's why I was talking about like the
AI inside the interface because um it
give too much freedom if it's a
conversation
>> because even the prompt need to be good
to have the desired output. That's why
for example for gen feed like I have the
prob bar but also I have like a list of
options to make sure it's the right uh
input to the replicate uh API right
>> to guide the user.
>> Exactly.
So
yeah,
I yeah because if you ask a dev what AI
will look like, it's going to be like
five screen and 25
uh CLI running and then you have an army
of of orchestration and did you see like
the the picture of the guy who created
cloudbot? That's exactly that.
>> No, I didn't.
But don't you think that eventually AI
will be in the background checking what
you're doing and then thinking about the
next step on what you need and just
showing it to you?
>> Yeah, it can be proactive. But um
>> if it sees my to-do list, it now I'm
writing it out one by one, but
eventually
it can just read all my data and see my
conversation, see my to-do list, and
know what it has to do and do it.
>> Yes. Uh okay. How long how long do you
think we uh uh we are away from that?
Well, if I think privacy and access is a
lot because cloudbot should be able to
do a lot.
>> Yeah. Like
and privacy is not a problem, right?
>> Not for them, but
>> like everyone can Okay. Yeah. Let's get
root root access to my computer on
something that can like uh basically
have um uh
all IP range on my local whatever
whatever
>> it can do whatever it wants.
>> Yeah, exactly. It's a 0000 loop back
blah blah blah.
>> I don't think people even understand who
use it that way what it can do. like uh
that
that's
uh stupid like the creator of clubbot
that's what he's doing.
>> Yeah. But I honestly think
this is just for the for the tweet and
for for making name because do you
really work like this? It's impossible
to focus on everything.
>> I have Okay. So
kind of I have um eight
um before Opus 4.6
>> Mhm.
>> I had uh eight uh PLI and then for one
um for one workspace I I split my uh
window into eight different uh
terminals. So then I just like prone the
P. I plan everything and then everyone
is like working on the P and um I I
don't really use work trees because all
of those task are still independent.
>> So I I don't really have overlaps and
stuff. So I don't use work trees. Um but
for example if I work on cloud and core
like for gen I I have eight like CLI on
one tab for uh cloud but for core I will
have another eight tab for core just
specifically on one screen.
>> Yeah but can you show the image again
because you have it all on one screen
and it's one laptop.
>> Yeah. So I would like to see a a time
loop of like five minutes if he stands
up, walks to the top left laptop.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And
I don't know.
Yeah, it could be a [__] uh
>> because these are nine laptops.
>> Yeah. Yeah. like what's the what's the
point of that like for example uh I have
oh yeah you can't see my you can't see
my mouse but uh I have the main screen
like basically that I have one screen
that looks like oh yeah no you can uh
that like look like the main screen
>> that's it
>> yeah and that I get you just have all
the windows open next to each other
>> yes but I think that's what a developer
will looks like uh like that looks like
right Yeah.
>> Yeah. And I also have three three
monitors
>> and I'm using them all. But eventually I
think at this moment everybody is doing
so much.
>> I'm really sure that the workload didn't
decrease but for most people it even
increased.
>> Yeah. But like okay so if you have
one orchestrator like okay also like a
uh what is his name?
that Peter. Yeah. So Peter um
ships on production code he didn't look
at.
>> Mhm.
>> So we don't even need to read the code
base anymore.
We basically right now my bottleneck is
testing the product generated by code
and codeex.
>> Yeah. Because you don't want it to make
mistakes. But when you pushed code like
a year ago, wasn't it more buggy on the
first release than now when cloud does
it?
>> Uh yeah, probably
>> for most apps, not about us.
>> Yeah, I know for sure. Um or even like
no like it's for me I feel like okay two
years ago you would ship a bike and then
like um uh like first a troller then a
bike then a car
>> and right now you just [__] like ship
a rocket
>> but one piece at a time like and it's
against everything that a a startup guy
entrepreneur should do because then you
end up in a devil hell which is actually
I'm doing it again but yeah whatever.
So, you buy another Mac Mini?
>> No, I I have one already. Like, I'm
streaming on Mac Studio. So, there's
that. But, um, it's not the best one for
having all of the LM stuff like Alex.
But, so I had to I tried I I downloaded
models to um
to set up uh like to have like
uncensored prompting and stuff because I
am doing some uncensored stuff. I think
whatever. Uh and um
yeah, it works like but it's not that
it's not that smart. It's not that big.
It's it's it's okay.
>> That's what needs to do.
>> Yeah, exactly. Um but um yeah, I mean
we we are we are orchestrating AI
already and it's only going to get
better slash worse with time,
I think. But so like all of that to say
that our experience with AI is way more
technical than any normies again like
we're gonna talk about that
>> even like a project manager in a big
corporate or u anyone who is working on
a desk
>> they need to manage a lot more than just
>> five AIs and we are doing AI fulltime.
>> Yeah.
I I don't know exactly where the the gap
is where um for people
using AI and not like how many
percentage of like workforce is actually
using AI
>> I don't think that much right
>> yeah but that that's nuts
>> and even other people they just use
because the their company isn't using it
they have their own private AI and they
put in the company questions in a
private AI.
>> Yeah.
>> And yeah, that's how you get leaks. So
>> they try in France to have like a French
AI stuff in the government and they stop
the pilot because it
>> it's a uncertain
uh future for sure.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's see what it does. We don't know.
>> Um, okay. So, uh, some people have wrote
in some nice article about all of it
here. Uh, so yeah, AI is killing B2B SAS
was posted by Nana Gold on yeah last
week. So SAS is the most profitable
business
on earth. It says to understand blah
blah blah and the market is AI is
bringing ex existential blah blah blah
blah. Sorry. Uh agent editors, let me
rephrase. Agent is bringing an
existential threat to a lot of business
SAS executive. How to keep asking
customers for renewal when every
customers feel that they can get
something better built with vibe coded
AI product. I don't think it's true.
>> No. And if they want to do it, most of
the customers don't know how to do it
themselves. So they hire somebody like
us and then you need to make a
comparison and how much is the onetime
setup fee versus
the monthly cost on a big SAS.
>> Yeah. Like
I think saying that okay we're going to
write code everything and we're going to
like stop the SAS subscription
and have a team internally like
maintaining a software. Mhm.
>> Um it's it's a good for a tweet but in
practice
I don't I don't I don't see it
because like yeah I don't know like for
examp like a big comp like Louis Vuitton
or yeah LVM like they're doing like all
of the AMS bag and stuff
>> are they going to have a team of vibe
coders internally to replace their
subscription budget that probably
represent like less than 10%
maybe 5% of their expenses.
>> No. And is the risk worth it? Because
now they got a full system, they're
making margins, they're making profit.
>> And if you cannot be sure that it works
100%, are you going to take the risk
that everything breaks down?
>> Exactly.
But I think on the on the the companies
that are not startups anymore but have
proven uh something a sales product or
MVP or whatever and when they are
scaling
>> and during scaling they don't have the
the budget to to go to the enterprise
SAS solutions
>> I think those customers
can do a good on for VIP coding. Yeah,
but like Okay, so all of the scallop uh
do they have the resources to have a
vibe coders team in house to
>> Yeah, but not in house, but they can
hire one.
>> Yeah. Okay. Ship [__] dev.
>> Yes. But yeah, and I they are used to
like how it used to go like two years
ago. So, oh yeah, we can build it, but
it takes a year. Well, it takes a week.
>> Yeah. if you know what you're doing
>> and it takes a week to have a MVP and
then like uh you can try it and then
yeah like again like uh add features on
top of it and even like okay people use
Salesforce and there is like billions of
[__] features on Salesforce but at
the end of the day you pay like 10 grand
a month and you use three.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And the only other feature
that you need is in the 20k
subscription.
That's always how it goes.
>> I I don't like I use it I use Salesforce
for
uh to build an app on top of it. Like in
my previous uh company
>> an integration for Salesforce, they have
like three different workflow to do an
integration in the [__] interface.
Kind of like Shopify but badly designed.
It is supposed to work when it's
finished, but getting there is hard.
>> Yeah. Like Yeah. And like and even like
the addressable maybe the go to market
is easier on Salesforce because then you
have all of the customers. I don't know.
Uh but yeah, that that was my experience
with Salforce and never again, bro.
>> Yeah, but there are like companies who
have like 50 people working for them and
the only thing they do is for bigger
companies integrate Salesforce.
That tells you how complex Salesforce
is.
>> Yeah, but use another SAS
>> or five the five people you need.
>> Just say I need Salesforce the
enterprise solution build it.
>> Do you think Salesforce will have to cut
price of the monthly sub or yearly
contract to compete with AI?
>> Yeah, but can they eventually?
I mean if they fire like 50% of their
workforce anyway. Yes.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Then it's no issue. But
they need to do something I think.
>> But still
you can just cut your prices like 50%.
>> I mean yeah no like not if you still pay
your software engineer like 1 million a
year and uh and you have like 200 of
them but if you know have 10
>> and you pay them two mill.
>> Yeah. But if they just do the normal
work and and they use AI to code, not
even VIP code, just do
>> Yeah.
>> slow work with AI. I think their deaths
are like working only 10 hours a week.
>> Yeah. But walk work walk 50 and then
>> Yeah.
>> Walk more.
>> Keep on going. The people who are in the
office, they don't want to work 40
hours. They want to get paid 40 hours.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. And they work like a few and the
rest is AI does everything and the and
and the boss is happy because he got the
deadline in time.
I think it's even like something else,
but like it's probably a culture issues
then because if you hire developers like
or nobody any anybody in in your staff
and uh they just want to leave for the
weekend uh you need to talk with HR with
with Karen in the HR to the team.
But I don't know. I especially at the AI
age like you can't sleep of what you are
you were you you you were doing for the
last 20 years because you got this
you're going to get [__]
>> Yeah. But we are not doing what we did
like six months ago.
>> Yeah. No no for sure. But like for us
Yes. Because like we are like a solo
founder like contractor whatever
whatever but like for Salesforce guy
like a Salesforce dev who is like
onboarding his customers
not customers like the sales c
Salesforce customers for the 1,00 times
and then it's the same integration
workflow that's going to be a six months
project and they only want to work like
uh 10 hours paid 40.
Yeah, it worked for a really short
period of time.
>> Yeah, exactly. And even like a big
company like Salesforce, sooner or later
they're going to get [__] if they only
hire that kind of guy.
>> Can slow down.
>> Well, I think they will they will I
think they are even already using AI.
No, no, of course like they push like a
Salesforce agent anywhere and I I I
can't find the Salesforce agent
uh sales
number
uh
uh agents Salesforce agent uh new
revenue
force agent force
6 for 60 billion. Okay. The AI AIdriven
platform blah blah blah or we generate
new revenue
check
one. So agent force it's a AIdriven
platform featuring autonomous agent that
endle revenue related task. Fair enough.
Uh key revenue metrics impact late 25
explosion era growth agent force in data
360 combined reach nearly 1.4 billion in
actual annual revenue. Jesus with 100%
uh year over year year overyear growth
rapid adoption 10k agent force deal
closed. Jesus they know to sell
Salesforce.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Well, I think first the smaller SAS
companies are going down and then it
will take some time but eventually the
big ones they have to adapt or just sync
with the rest.
Yeah, it's going to be like the middle
curve of the whole market will think and
yeah like you at the top of the finel
when like you are Sal force and you work
with government and big cop then you
save and the micro SAS can probably sell
to 10 customers 20 customers and then
dies and you go to the next one. Yeah I
mean cool
>> like that.
Uh oh yeah because uh basically what
happened here on the NASDAQ
because uh yeah software stock was was
deepen NASDAQ Morgans County software
index has diverged widely since July
2025.
>> Yeah the moment when it started.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. It's relation between vibe coding
and B2B SAS sales. A new problem for B2B
SAS is that AI customers can get
something working with VI coding, but it
can also give you like a MVP and then
you give it to a real dev and then it
can build a better software because you
voded something.
>> Yeah.
>> Like uh every interaction is a world to
pump workflow apps. Uh whatever they
build simply works.
uh non-programmer don't know any of the
neons one uh one series eco told me they
reating the quarterly renewal of the
engineering productivity software
because they along with an engineer
using GitHub and notion API they were
paying 30k to a popular tool and they
are not going to renew it anymore
uh impact B2B sales if customers feels
like they are being served exactly what
they want True. They more like they are
more likely to ch what if if customer
they are not being ser
>> editor you have to edit. I need to check
if uh the AI understood what I asked to
edit.
Uh previously you would uh no blah blah
blah blah blah if customers feel like
they are not being ser exactly like they
want to they are more likely to churn.
The reason behind all of this is that
customers demanding more from their B2B
vendors because they know what's
possible.
>> Do they?
>> They don't. They don't. But customers
are like Yeah. We know AI can do
everything. Build it.
>> Yeah. like uh
for your experience like dealing with
customers and like customer request
stuff like do they ask you to work
faster because you have a a clothe as an
employee know
>> well they compare they don't ask me to
work faster but they compare to and to
other people who are using AI and I see
a lot of people just cold emailing
customers hey we see you use this
solution uh we can vi code it they don't
say v code but we can v code it within a
week for these costs and they just cold
emails so I get my customers to give me
those emails from hey they say they can
do it faster and they can do it smarter
with AI and most of the time when they
do like a first call they see that it is
just somebody trying to sell ours and
>> yeah you still need to know exactly how
everything should go and what you're
asking the AI. It's not as easy as build
this.
>> Yeah. I mean, yeah, like for me, I build
from scratch like Genfit and stuff, so I
don't have like to take care of like
legacy system and integration [__]
right?
>> Yeah. But you didn't build it in a week.
It still is a proper build.
>> That's a problem, too.
>> Yeah.
>> But uh Yeah. Like
Yeah,
because Yeah. Maybe even like for
example you have AI that can maybe
simplify
the migration from Salesforce to another
vendor
like
>> even for like the big and uh hard
solutions to migrate like for example
when you subscribe to Salesforce like
two years ago you are not a customers
you are like a you you're a slave to
Salesforce because now your business is
completely integrated into it and you
can't leave it anymore. So, you're going
to pay um you're going to pay your bill
for the next uh 20 years and your bill
is going to 100x but you can live
anymore because everything is in it,
right? So
maybe AI can also simplify the migration
from one tool to another because again
it's like
if you need a consultant to migrate,
>> AI can help you migrate.
>> Yeah. And you don't need to migrate
everything at once. You can just do it
part by part.
>> Ju just start setting up this the the
most important systems for your company
so your company doesn't rely on another
SAS company.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But I can
>> Yeah. Make sure that all the data is in
your database and not in Salesforce
database. And if you need some some
other stuff, just set up the API and do
it like a hybrid of your own and then
just slowly keep on progressing and
migrating everything to your own system.
>> Do you think like Salesforce customers
are migrating the database out of
Salesforce stuff? I don't think so. They
chose Salesforce because it's the
biggest company software ever.
>> Yeah, but when people when company
grows, they want to have the data on
their own servers.
>> Yeah. Especially when you have to put a
learning layers on top of your data too.
>> Yeah.
And storage is expensive at SAS
companies because they charge you a lot
if you just do it on AWS or any other
option.
>> That's true.
>> It's so much cheaper.
>> Yeah. Put everything on ABS kit.
>> Yeah.
Um Okay. Yeah. Auto survive BS system of
record. Yeah. That that's the data,
right? is the entire company workflow on
your platform you are line of business
task you are integrated into the
existing they know your UI and they rely
on you on the dayto-day which is
basically like what we said with
salesforce like that's that um for
example to create thatization I won't
think I won't think any SAS I would just
code one myself yes uh many of the
popular tools blah blah blah being a
system of record mean you embedded so
deeply that then no choice but to win my
prediction is that we will see more SAS
companies go from application layer to
offer their robust uh SO
system of record as their primary
selling point. Yeah. Basically, you sell
the output
over like over the platform.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. Yeah. Security authentication.
Yeah. Whatever.
>> Yeah. But that also SAS just has like
fallbacks, um load balancers, multiple
servers. It doesn't go offline. And if
you build it yourself and you have one
server, you need to think about so much
more.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But like uh if you have a
SAS, you need a load balancer because
you have like 1,000 customers at the
same time that doing like crazy [__] on
your platform. If you vibe code your own
intern app, if you're not like LVMH,
then there is like 15 people and you can
you can spin up a wellway or like a EC2
instance if you're technical.
>> And one day loss will kill your company.
>> What? one day those will kill your
entire production for half a day.
Also I think like SAS can be like you
know um so company are using SAS because
if something like that happens that's
not on them and they are legally um they
are going [__] up the SAS provider
because they [__] up one day of uh
>> yeah that's so stupid because eventually
your company is having the issue and you
can yeah you can still say you you owe
us money because you you made a mistake
but Yeah.
>> No, but wait, what?
>> You can blame the SAS, but you want to
you still want your own company to
always be okay. You don't want to go
have it go offline.
>> Yes, of course. But like um
at least the like uh uh Jean Paul at the
IT service doesn't is not going to lose
his job because uh
>> it will it will be it will be you that
they're going to throw under the bus and
not internal guy.
>> Yeah. You can just point at somebody
else.
>> Exactly. Which is like Yeah. Hi
corporate. But then another question,
how much uh SAS subscriptions do you
have left in your company?
>> Uh a lot
without the AIS. Um
not a lot. And I think this year like
that was more of one of my goal for this
year too is like to basically v code all
of the subscription I have like for
example like clean my Mac and stuff like
that. uh I'm one skill away of like
cleaning my mic for for real.
>> So
yeah, like for example, I can say okay
like in WW clean all of the node modules
uh build artifact blah blah blah and
clean the cache and like an app like
clean my Mac doesn't really scan that
because it's not just for dev you know I
mean so yeah
>> yeah you can just talk to it and say
what it needs to do.
>> Exactly. But like again for us we're
going to talk to a terminal
>> but like for the end user they're still
going to download in my Mac to clean the
Mac.
>> Yeah. And why should they not? It works.
>> Exactly.
But so AI is not going to change
anything for SAS.
>> Yeah. For small group of people it is.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I don't know if we're
going to have an answer to this question
at the end of this.
>> No, not within the last few minutes.
>> Uh yeah, adapt to the customers not the
other way around. The time of asking
customer to change how they work are
gone. Yeah. No sounds vendor that
differentiate by being ultra
customizable win the earth of c. I
I would say like product that are
opinated are kind of like more
interesting to use than having again
like [__] Salesforce when you can
activate all of the [__] settings you
want and then it's like a big mashed
potato of features over something that
uh like notion
and I have a notion it's kind of like a
yeah if you don't know what to do it
could be complicated but like Yeah.
>> Uh, a simple UXUI that just do does the
job. That's it. It's over.
>> Yeah.
just it just like I like the biggest
shift is probably like output
like people will pay for the output of
it no matter what
>> over like the all of the consideration
of like the SAS UX UI business model
like for example having a a seat
business model like pay per seat doesn't
make sense anymore
>> no it just needs to get the the job done
>> and yeah exactly Exactly. And like you
pay per usage, you pay per request, you
pay per like whatever action you have
>> storage.
>> Yeah. And it's also align the incentive
between the customers and the SAS
because the better your product is, the
more action you trigger on the UX UI,
>> the UI. So the more you get paid because
you have a good margin on top of the
token used.
>> Yes.
>> Okay, cool. I like that. Should we
should we wrap it up? Yeah, that's a
good one.
>> So, we didn't really answer the
question.
>> No, no, no. We did.
>> Oh, okay. We did.
>> By the end of of of this quarter this
year, SAS is still here.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. Wait, wait. You're
going to do the conclusion, bro. Of the
video. It's going to be the end of the
video. No, the other one.
Yeah.
>> Oh, it's it's the big conclusion.
So, yeah. I think the conclusion is SAS
is not there. Not yet.
>> Yeah, not yet. Just wait.
>> We will redo the conversation in six
months.
>> Too much swap.
>> Yes, let's do let's do the same the same
stream in six months and see where it
goes.
>> Yeah.
>> Nice. Okay. So, yeah, for everyone who
has a subscription, uh maybe you can
keep it. Maybe
>> maybe you hire us to just rebuild it.
>> Exactly.
Thank you everyone and yeah, thank you
for watching the live stream. Uh if you
ever watch and uh yeah, if you ever
watch this live stream until the end,
said um SAS is not dead in the comment
section so we know that you will watch
it. Cool. Thank you.